how was it being raised by your by your
grandmother man like you know i mean the
old school principal you know you know
that curiosity i love you afraid to beat
your ass
boom
and now now you know that you know
that's the hot debate among parenting
and even in the uh the school circles
about
about corporal punishment and there
there is definitely an old school and
especially in the i think in the black
and latin communities of where you know
you step out of line mom and dad smack
you and i can say that for me
it worked to a degree my my grandmother
didn't have to beat my ass more than
just a couple times in my life for me to
shake some of the friends that i was
with and i kind of stayed on a path
getting into grandparents getting in the
beat and that ass that's just it's just
a twist
you're not going to keep but you're
going to feel like you're dying
that's just a specialty belts switches
the extension they might even tell you
to go get your [ __ ] depending on who
your grandmother is yes and this is
foreign to some kids
watching this this is foreign to them
they know not to bring those little
swiss they know nothing they know they
bring them a [ __ ] a monster turned a
tamer you bring a little switch you dead
[ __ ] because you thought that if i get
well if i get the skinny thing then it
won't that will cut your ass uh
so i learned quick yeah
don't have to
save you that depression or mission
whatever it was no you're talking about
like you discipline and hitting your
kids are you talking about talking about
like the the you know the stick and you
know when you're beating them let's
teach them stay in line for the big
mammal that's what it's all about most
of our characteristics comes from that
a slave
ancestors there there's definitely a
generational trauma
that plays out all the time even with
corporal punishment so in talking about
you know being raised old school
i didn't necessarily mind it because
i think it
it worked for whatever reason but i do
think that especially in the black
community
just turning to when i'm a whoop your
ass
that
in some households is a substitute for
let me listen to you first see what's
going on with you and let me parent you
hands-on yeah versus i'm gonna parent
you and beat you the beating doesn't
necessarily help
that's what i think it's just my opinion
it's like capital punishment we've seen
everybody you know i know if i do this
they're going to kill me the
government's going to kill me but still
it doesn't stop people from killing
people mm-hmm no serious and depends on
what state you're in if i shoot you and
they're gonna hang me off if i kill him
or her they're gonna um
fight and swap me or something crazy
electrocute me
and it still doesn't prevent people from
murders murder rated even higher because
the end result isn't the thing and
that's the thing with corporal
punishment you don't understand that
right yeah it's even higher the murder
rate is even higher since the
electricity and all that stuff came back
into existence
instead of looking at the end goal of if
you do this crime
i'm gonna kill you or i'm gonna hang you
i'm gonna do this
let's go to where the root of the
problems are why are these people
committing crimes what can you do to
alleviate all of that and that's not
where the money's being spent it's being
spent on incarceration and the end
result instead of the programs that
would help people not commit the crimes
you know how you stop crying like you
stop hating on
you ain't nothing i don't have to stop
pain
if you can't stop paying
you can't stop all that all this is
coming from pain well there's an empathy
piece too because you have to understand
that people are going through pain and i
think this is the conversation that's
happening now
because of the pandemic and because of
the black lives matter movement and
everything that's happening
there's a lot of people screaming out in
pain exactly and that's the thing is how
do we deal that pain and that's the part
i think that pisses me off when i listen
to people especially even people that
call themselves allies they don't want
to have or listen to certain race
conversations because well i don't want
to hear that i didn't do it i wasn't a
slave owner i like black people i'm your
friend don't talk over us
just listen to what's being said if you
show some empathy and go oh you know i i
hear that
kindness and compassion
they're more powerful but on the flip
side mike you know what i'm thinking is
we also need to have
kindness and compassion for each other
and empathy for each other because it
goes both ways yeah it goes both ways
[Music]